find a natural shampoo that does not use
any sulfate how much shampoo strip or
damage ha isn't something you can tell
from Individual ingredients so factant
in shampoos are the cleaning ingredients
these little pink tadpoles the way they
work is through a super molecular
process it's a whole bunch of them
working together it is actually the
exact ratio of ingredients in them that
make something stripping or not that's
why in good housekeeping's test they
found that A sulfate containing shampoo
strip dye less than sulfate free
shampoos even though on their own
sulfates are probably going to be more
stripping the worst effect factant for
your hair hands down is natural it's
soap soaps were the first effect factant
used for everything and they have a
whole bunch of problems that we've
solved by inventing brand new synthetic
molecules they react with high water and
they form scum this is exactly what was
happening to people's hair and it was as
hard to get off hair as it is to get off
your tiles it's actually where that
whole rinse your hair with vinegar after
you wash it to make your hair shiny
thing comes from people had to use DIY
house cleaning hacks on their hair to
make soap not do this